Speaker 1: . In the United States, we have due
process we are innocent until proven guilty. That
is a good thing. That is not something I would
ever seek to change or violate or argue against.
But as a program that is just based on my opinion
on things, sometimes I give you my opinion of
people's behavior, and sometimes people's behavior
is not indicative of them being innocent. Now,
courts adjudicate guilt vs. lack of guilt.
They don't adjudicate innocence, and that
is the standard that applies in courts. Donald
Trump's behavior continues colloquially without
violating anyone's due process, without saying
Trump should be charged or convicted of any crime.
Just observing his behavior as a human, it is
not the behavior of an innocent person. And we
are now learning about Donald Trump's latest
another attempt the latest attempt to block
January six investigators from getting access to
information about what the hell he was up to in
the days leading up to and during the Trump riots.
There is a very interesting Politico article,
and even actually the article is called Trump
Makes and Loses Overnight Bid to block January
6th investigators run Philip Koski, who's
doing a great job covering this stuff,
tweeted this morning. In an odd move. Late last
night, Trump filed an emergency motion to block
documents from the National Archives from being
turned over to congressional investigators this
Friday. Odd because the judge hasn't even ruled
yet on his previous objection. This is not
the behavior of an innocent person or someone with
nothing to hide going to the Politico article. If
you blinked, you missed it. Former President Trump
filed an emergency request to a federal judge late
Monday night last night to prevent the National
Archives from sending sensitive records to the
January 6th Committee investigators by Friday.
And just after midnight, Judge Tania Chacon
rejected it, contending the request itself was
legally defective and premature. Not shocking.
After the four years we had of Trump's people, the
people around Trump making invalid legal arguments
in various courts that it is continuing. The
unusual exchange happened in a span of two hours,
and it came as chunkin is already considering an
earlier request by Trump to prevent Congress from
peering into his White House's records about his
attempt to overturn the 2020 election. Trump sued
to block the archives from turning the records
over last month after Joe Biden declined to assert
executive privilege on his behalf. We covered that
at the time. The archives indicate it would turn
the papers over to lawmakers by Friday unless
a court intervened. Chuck had heard arguments
in the suit last week promised to rule quickly
on the initial emergency request from Trump.
She seemed inclined to reject it, questioning
the legal basis for a former president to claim
executive privilege over records when the sitting
president and Congress disagree. The archives
indicated Trump is seeking to block at least 750
pages out of an initial 1500 unearthed in response
to the Jan. six committee's request for records
about Trump's attempt to overturn the election.
Many of the papers are culled from the files of
senior Trump aides like Mark Meadows, Stephen
Miller and Patrick Philbin. They also include
This is important call and visitor logs. Who
was Trump speaking to in the days leading up to
leaving office and leading up to the Trump riots,
and who was visiting Trump at the White House
in those same important days? Trump's attorney,
Jesse Banel, issued his second request Monday
night, asking Cohen to approve an administrative
stay of her own ruling even before she issued
it. That way, Bennett argued Trump would have
a chance to appeal her decision before the
archives began delivering hundreds of pages
to congressional investigators. So again, Trump
hasn't been charged with any crimes. I'm not
saying he should be. I'm not saying that any any
jury should rule any way. Every time we do this,
I get emails from right wingers saying,
David, don't you believe in due process? Don't
you believe until innocent until proven guilty? I
not only do I believe in those things, my believe
believe in those things is irrelevant to
the fact that that is the system we have
in the justice system. This is not the justice
system here. This is not about guilt or innocence.
This is about Donald Trump's attempt to block
records from being given to the committee. And
it is not colloquially speaking my opinion and
that of many in my audience from the emails I'm
getting. This is not the behavior of an innocent
person. This is not the behavior of someone with
nothing to hide. So we are going to continue
to follow this and we will see if and when
these documents ultimately get to the January 6th
commission, what they uncover now, as a reminder,
much like with the debate about Trump's. Tax
records and the legal wrangling around it.
This is about the release of these
documents to the January 6th Committee.
It is not about their public release, so it's
not like if the judge says we're not stopping it,
we get access to these documents. We might
if they leak or subsequently released. But
it is at least in the immediate. Just about
releasing these documents to those investigating
the January six riots. Just a reminder they
might leak. I would not encourage that leaking,
but if they leak, they would certainly
look at them. Let's put it that way.